hi it's larry here of xbox live's major
nelson you know working here at xbox is
great I get to see some really cool
stuff but I'm telling you there's
something magical about the moment when
i get to see something for the very
first time and i'm very surprised this
next appt did just that xbox go to red x
say hello to the first app for reddit
ever built exclusively for a console
coming to xbox one better yet it's
available right now as a long time user
of reddit i had the chance to put the
app through its paces so let's take a
little tour of how it works and i'll
highlight some of my favorite features
first you'll see the main page here
where you can see what's hot and what's
new on the site if you click into one of
the posts you can of course check out
the comments reply yourself upvote or
downvote just as you would on reddit now
here's a feature that I appreciate
you'll see as I scroll down that posts
aren't broken out into pages you can
just scroll endlessly also for posts
with pictures i can easily pan and zoom
getting right up close and personal with
my meme or picture of choice even better
posts that contain albums are neatly
sorted for you so you can flick between
each image easily not only kind of you
animated gifs but i can also fast
forward rewind or pause them and yes
embedded youtube videos can be played
within the app now while surfing around
reddit is fun it's better when you're
logged into your account and checking
the subreddits you care about once
you're logged in all your chosen
subreddits will be ready and waiting for
you of course you can also start your
own thread input.text using your xbox
one controller or using Xbox SmartGlass
last month reddit had more than 114
million unique visitors with more than
190 countries casting more than 22
million votes with more than 5 billion
pages served that's some serious
community involvement and we welcome the
reddit community to red X for xbox one
available today in the US and canada i'm
larry herb xbox live's major nelson see
I reddit